>> BECOME SHELL NEW REPORT
POLITICO NANCY PELOSI
CLASHED WITH JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN JERRY NADLER OVER
WHETHER TO BEGIN IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
BECAUSE OF INSTEAD OF
IMPEACHMENT SHE WANTS TO
SEAT PRESIDENT IN PRISON.
POLITICO REPORTING, QUOTE
NADLER PRESSED PELOSI TO
ALLOW HIS COMMITTEE TO
LAUNCH AN IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY AGAINST TRUMP.
PELOSI STOOD FIRM
REITERATING THAT SHE ISN'T
OPEN TO THE IDEA OF
IMPEACHING TRUMP AT THIS
TIME.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE HIM
IMPEACHED, I WANT TO SEE HIM
IN PRISON.
PELOSI'S COMMENTS REPORTEDLY
HAPPENING DURING A CLOSED
DOOR MEETING WITH TOP
DEMOCRATS ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS SOUNDS
LIKE TO ME?
SHE IS JUST THROWING THE
LEFT A BONE TO MAKE IT SEEM
LIKE YEAH, I WANT TO GET
TRUMP REALLY BADLY.
>> Dana: THERE IS A SCHOOL
OF THOUGHT ON THE LEFT THAT
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
IMPEACH BECAUSE THE SENATE
WILL NEVER VOTE ALONG THOSE
LINES.
>> Jesse: ALSO ON THE LEFT.
THAT'S A BREAKING NEWS
ALERT.
>> Dana: KEEP PUSHING ON THE
COURT SYSTEM.
ONCE WE BEAT HIM OUT OF
OFFICE THEN HE WILL GO TO
JAIL.
THERE A SCHOOL OF THOUGHT
THERE.
THE THING IS ABOUT -- I
BELIEVE THAT SHE SAID.
THIS THEY ARE NOT REALLY
DENYING IT.
I CAN IMAGINE IT.
THE THING IS THAT THAT
DEMOCRAT DEBATE IS IN THREE
WEEKS.
REMEMBER WHEN NEWT GINGRICH
CALLED WAS IT MITT ROMNEY A
LIAR AT THE DEBATE IN SOUTH
CAROLINA?
REMEMBER.
>> Juan: I REMEMBER HE
ATTACKED ME.
>> Dana: WHERE DO YOU GO
FROM THERE?
IF NANCY PELOSI THE LEADER
OF THE DEMOCRATS IS SAYING I
WANT TO PUT HIM IN PRISON.
ING WHAT WHAT THE OTHER
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO TRY
TO DO TO TOP THAT SO THEY
CAN GET A HEADLINE.
>> Juan: LET ME INTERPRET
FOR ALL OF YOU.
SHE IS NOT SAYING ANYTHING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
I THINK WHAT SHE IS SAYING
REALLY WE NEED TO BEAT HIM
IN 2020 AND THEN ONCE HE IS
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE, AND
WITH ALL HIS PROTECTIONS,
THAT THAT POINT WE CAN LOOK
AND SEE WHAT PROSECUTION IS
POSSIBLE.
>> Dana: DIDN'T I JUST SAY
THAT?
>> Juan: I'M AGREEING WITH
YOU.
THAT'S THE INTERPRETATION.
IT'S NOT SAYING THROW HIM IN
JAIL.
ONLY POLITICIAN I KNOW THAT
TALKS ABOUT THROWING THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS IN JAIL.
OH, I KNOW HIS NAME.
WON'T MENTION.
>> Jesse: LOCK HER UP.
>> Juan: PEGGY NOONAN IN THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAID
LET'S HAVE THE HOUSE CENSOR
HIM.
YOU CAN HAVE CONDEMN HIM.
EVERYBODY IS LOOKING FOR
SOME WAY TO DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE BUT WE DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER?
>> PRISON POLITICS NOW.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO GO
TO THE DEBATE AND SAY TRUMP
SHOULD BE IN GITMO AND
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON THEY
SHOULD STILL KEEP IT OPEN.
THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE GOING
TO SEND HIM.
>> Jesse: SHE PROBABLY
LEAKED IT TO POLITICO.
>> Katie: SHE PROBABLY DID.
I'M LETTING YOU KNOW YOU
SHOULD REALLY BE IN PRISON.
>> Greg: EVERYBODY WANTS
SOMEBODY TO BE IN PRISON,
FLIGHT.
>> Jesse: AT THIS TABLE?
>> Greg: YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL
ABOUT MAROON 5?
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MAROON 5
IN PRISON.
MAXIMUM SECURITY.
AWAY FROM THINK RECORDING
STUDIO.
I THINK SHE THREW IT OFF
LIKE SHE JUST THREW IT OUT
THERE.
YOU KNOW, I USED THE SAME
PHILOSOPHY WORDS VS. DEEDS
WITH TRUMP THAT YOU DO WITH
PELOSI.
PEOPLE JUST SAY STUFF.
THEY SAY A LOT OF THE STUFF.
IT'S OFF THE CUFF.
>> Jesse: LET'S LOCK HILLARY
UP.
HE DIDN'T DO IT.
>> Jesse: HE DIDN'T SAY
THAT.
>> Juan: HE DIDN'T DIRECT
ANYBODY WHO LOCK HER UP.